ein Hinweis bevor es losgeht in diesem
Podcast werden unter anderem
Verstümmelungen und Kannibalismus
thematisiert denjenigen denen solche
Schilderungen zu nahe gehen raten wir
vom Hören ab Tatort Deutschland
präsentiert den dunklen Januar jeden Tag
ein neuer Kriminalfall ein tägliches
Tatort Deutschlands Spezial mein Name
ist Guard und ich wünsche euch eine
spannende krimi-zeit
moinsen und mein Name ist Natalie Strauß
wir präsentieren euch Kriminalfälle aus
der Vergangenheit und der Gegenwart die
uns auch wenn sie vielleicht
Jahrhunderte zurücklegen noch immer
faszinieren beschäftigen oder wie in
unserem heutigen Fall schlichtweg
Entsetzen mit mir am Mikro ist eine
hello hi grüß Dich Natalie und hallo
liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer wir
erzählen heute von Fritz Haarmann einem
der bekanntesten und schlimmsten
Serienmörder der deutschen
Kriminalgeschichte mindestens
22 Morde gehen auf sein Konto er tötete
teilweise im Wochentakt Fritz Hamann ist
auch bekannt als der schlechter der
Metzger oder der Werwolf vor allem aber
als der Vampir von Hannover da muss ich
auch direkt sagen als Fantasy Vampir-Fan
finde ich diesen Begriff sowas und doof
weil viele von uns ja Vampire mit etwas
irgendwie mystisch romantischem
verbinden alte Schlösser Vollmond
schicke Kostüme das ganze Drum und Dran
ja aber an dem worüber wir heute reden
ist rein gar nichts romantisch es ist
einfach nur schrecklich und entsetzlich
von bitteren Anfang bis zum Ende und
Leute hier noch einmal eine kurze
Warnung dieser Fall ist wirklich heftig
das sagen wir oft aber diesmal ist diese
Warnung noch dringender als sonst wir
springen direkt rein das Folgende ist
eine Aussage des Täters vor Gericht im
Jahr 1924 aufgeschrieben vom Prozess
Beobachter Georg Lessing
ich habe nicht die Absicht gehabt die
jungen Leute umzubringen
es ist vorgekommen dass Knaben immer
wieder kamen ich habe sie dann vor mir
schützen wollen ich wusste wenn ich
wieder meine Tour habe dann passiert was
ich habe geweint
macht mich nur nicht immer wild wir
Balken uns manchmal stundenlang und ich
dachte oft Gott oh Gott wo soll das hin
ich habe mich mit ganzem Leiber auf die
jungen Leute geworfen sie waren durch
das herumtreiben und die Ausschweifungen
der mattet ich habe ihren Adamsapfel
durchgebissen zugleich wohl auch mit den
Händen gewirkt und gedrosselt an der
Leiche brach ich zusammen
ich mache mir deinen schwarzen Kaffee
den Toten legte ich auf den Boden und
hat ein Tuch übers Gesicht dann sieht er
einen nicht so an
[Musik]
bitte was wer war dieser ich will ihn
gar nicht Menschen wer konnte so etwas
Grausames tun
Mirko am besten gehst du jetzt noch mal
ein paar Jahrzehnte zurück und erzählst
uns harmons Lebensweg
frittermann wird am 25 oktober 1879 in
Hannover geboren er ist das sechste Kind
der Familie die Mutter stellt Zigarren
her der Vater ist lokomotivhalter die
Kindheit ist geprägt von seiner Liebe
zur Mutter und der Abneigung gegen den
Vater die sich zum Hass auf ihn steigert
der Heizer ist tyrannisch und
alkoholabhängig Hermann wird später
eingeben dass er als Zehnjähriger von
ihm sexuell missbraucht wurde anderen
Quellen zufolge habe ihn einer seiner
älteren Brüder über längere Zeit
missbraucht
Jahre später beschuldigt Haman seinen
Vater auch einen Kollegen getötet und
die Mutter vergiftet zu haben
eine Untersuchung kommt zu dem Schluss
dass an diesen letzten Behauptungen
nichts dran sei sondern Spekulation
halten wir uns fern was aber klar ist er
hätte definitiv keine glückliche
wahrscheinlich sogar eine äußerst
schreckliche Kindheit aber das alles ist
natürlich überhaupt gar keine Erklärung
für das was dann am Ende aus wurde es
gibt auch keine direkte Linie von einer
schlimmen Kindheit zum Verbrechen mit 16
wird Fritz Hamann von einer Nachbarin
verführt und soll seinerseits
Nachbarskinder missbraucht haben ein
Strafverfahren wird eingestellt
stattdessen wird der Jugendliche in
einer Heiland stellt eingewiesen
dort diagnostiziert man eine
Intelligenzminderung oder in den damals
üblichen Worten
unheilbaren Schwachsinn außerdem
attestiert man Fritz Hamann
gemeingefährlichkeit
ihr kann fliehen und setzt sich in die
Schweiz ab
nach seiner Rückkehr nach Hannover
verlobt sich Hamann die Verlobung wird
jedoch nach drei Jahren wieder aufgelöst
im Jahr 1900 Hamann ist 21 Jahre alt
folgt die Einberufung zum Militärdienst
aus dem er 1902 wieder entlassen wird
aufgrund von Nervenschwäche und
erheblichem Schwachsinn er wird für
erwerbsunfähig erklärt und mit einem
militärrente Versehen im Folgenden Gerät
Harman auf die schiefe Bahn die Jahre
von 1905 bis 1980 verbringt er
größtenteils im Gefängnis was ihn davor
bewahrt in das Schlimmste morgen jener
Zeit zu geraten den Ersten Weltkrieg
er sitzt für kleine Delikte zumindest
wenn man sie mit dem vergleicht was
später kommen sollte
Diebstahl Betrug Körperverletzung
Beleidigung aber auch wegen sexueller
Unzucht mit männlichen Minderjährigen
nach seiner Entlassung lebt Harman in
der roten Reihe Nummer 2 einem schiefen
Fachwerkhaus in der Calenberger Neustadt
die Altstadt von Hannover ist zu jeder
Zeit geprägt von Armut und Verbrechen
aber auch von
legalem und
illegalen Vergnügen es gibt
Prostituierte und Zuhälter Diebe und
Hela einen lebhaften Schwarzmarkt ohne
denen in den Jahren nach dem Ersten
Weltkrieg keine deutsche Stadt auskommt
es gibt einschlägige unterweltkneipen
Elend und falschen Glanz Verzweiflung
und verzweifelte lebenslos und natürlich
auch Treffpunkte für Homosexuelle
zudem muss man wissen Homosexualität
zwischen Männern ist verboten noch gilt
der berüchtigte Paragraph 175 der erst
1994 endgültig aus dem Strafgesetzbuch
gestrichen wird ein Mann der mit einem
anderen Mann Unzucht treibt oder sich
von ihm zu Unzucht missbrauchen lässt
wird mit Gefängnis bestraft in dieser
Zeit und diesem Umfeld verschwindet im
September der 17-Jährige Friedl rote
Friedl soll eigentlich für das Examen
lernen stattdessen bummelt er und treibt
sich in der Stadt herum
um ein wenig Geld zu haben verkaufte die
Zivilkleidung seines Vaters der zu
dieser Zeit noch in der Front ist
irgendwann kehrt er von seinen
Streifzügen nicht mehr nach Hause zurück
die Mutter und der kurz darauf
heimkehrende Vater suchen ihren Sohn und
stellen nachdem die Polizei sich anfangs
nicht für den Fall interessiert
eingehende Ermittlungen an
schließlich finden sie Friedels Freunde
Paul Helmut und Hans erst wollen sie
nicht sagen doch schließlich beichten
sie ihre Geschichte
sie hätten in einem Café einen feinen
Herrn kennengelernt einen
Kriminalbeamten ja genau dieser feine
her und angebliche Kriminalbeamte ist
Fritz Haarmann klingt erstmal nach dem
klassischen Hochstapler ein
Kleinkrimineller der sich als
vertrauenswürdiger Beamter der
Kriminalpolizei ausgibt
aber so hoch hat er man gar nicht
gestapelt er ist zwar kein Beamter aber
verdient sich immerhin ein bisschen Geld
als Spitze für das Diebstahl Dezernat
der Polizei dazu merkt euch das denn das
wird später noch wichtig okay Mirko wie
geht's weiter der feine Herr so
berichten friedlos Freunde habe sie
beschenkt und in den Stadtwald
mitgenommen und dort habe er sie
verführt
Friedel sei ihm besonders nahe gewesen
und habe eines Tages erzählt ich bin
schon in seiner Wohnung gewesen da
müsieren wir uns und rauchen
endlich wird die Polizei aktiv der feine
Herr und angebliche Kriminalbeamte wird
aufgespürt es ist Fritz Haarmann
der echte Kriminalbeamte Brauns stürmt
es nachts Hermanns Wohnung und
überrascht ihn mit einem großen
schlanken jungen im Bett ein weiterer
Schulfreund Friedels wie sich
herausstellt der junge Mann und Hamann
werden abgeführt doch von Friedl rote
fehlt jede Spur
Hamann wandert für neun Monate wegen
Unzucht mit Minderjährigen ins Gefängnis
der Vermissten Fall Friedl rote wird
ungelöst zu den Akten gelegt Jahre
später wird Hermann gestehen den
17-Jährigen getötet zu haben vor Gericht
sagt der aus damals als der
Kriminalbeamte uns verhaftete steckte
der Kopf des ermordeten Knaben unter
Zeitungspapier hinterm Ofen ich habe ihn
später im Stöckener Friedhof verscharrt
das ist erst der erste Mord der erste
von mindestens zwei Dutzend doch es soll
noch ein paar Jahre vergehen bis das
große töten beginnt erst einmal lernt
Harman so etwas wie die Liebe seines
Lebens kennen 1919 Fritz Haarmann ist
inzwischen 40 Jahre alt und lernt den
20-Jährigen hans-kranz kennen sie führen
eine intensive aber gleichzeitig auch
offene Beziehung sie teilt sich
zeitweise eine Wohnung oder besser
gesagt ein Zimmer zur Untermiete in der
neuen Straße Nummer 8 ein vor allem von
Arbeiter vermehren bevor und das Haus
dessen Rückseite direkt am Fluss alleine
liegt aber man sagt über ganz wenn der
Hans mich küsste wenn mich so lieb in
den Arm nahm und mich streichelte dann
war ich weg dann konnte er mit mir
machen was er wollte
Hamanns Wohnung entwickelt sich zu einem
turbulenten Ort sie dient als
Handelsplatz für Tauschgeschäfte und
helaware es gibt Trinkgelage und
Nachbarn berichten von
Geschlechtsverkehr mit wechselnden
Partnern und Frauen außerdem verdient er
sich ein wenig Geld indem er in seiner
Wohnung Fleisch zu Wurst und Sülze
verarbeitet klingt unvorstellbar wer
heute gar nicht mehr möglich aber damals
war das gar nicht mal so unüblich
trotzdem wird er später wie euch
vielleicht denken können zu
unappetitlichen Gerüchten führen und es
hilft ihm sicher nicht dass die Nachbarn
anders Geräusch eines Fleischwolfes
gewöhnt sind und das Knacken von Knochen
die mit einem Ball zerteilt werden die
eigentliche Mordserie beginnt 1923
Hamann ist er bereits 45 Jahre alt seine
Opfer sind zwischen 10 und 22 Jahren alt
Jungs und junge Männer oft verlassen
fortgespürt und gestrandet in den Wirren
der Zeit unsicher auf der Suche nach
einem Ort um zu bleiben nach einer
Schulter zum Anlehnen nach etwas zu
Essen und ein bisschen Sicherheit
manche vielleicht auch auf der Suche
nach Liebe und Abenteuer
Harman findet sie in den Gassen der
Altstadt meist jedoch in den warte
Seelen des Hauptbahnhofs als
Polizeispitzel hat Hermann ungehinderten
Zutritt zu seinem Jagdrevier auch nachts
und ohne Fahrkarte niemand verdächtigt
den feinen Herren der für die Kripo
arbeitet alle jungen Männer anspricht
und Sie unter vorwenden mitnimmt
angeblich auf die Polizeiwache
er loggt die Jungs unter verschiedenen
Vorwänden in seine Wohnung oft hat er
Sex mit ihnen er nennt sie meine Puppen
jungs das war eine damals übliche
Bezeichnung für männliche Prostituierte
mit einigen treibt er sich wochenlang
herum viele lässt er einfach gehen doch
für mindestens 23 Kinder Jugendliche und
junge Erwachsene gibt es keinen kommen
beißt sie in den Hals durch beißt ihren
Adamsapfel und wirkt sie dabei zu Tode
zwischen februar 1923 und juni 1924
mautdet er beinahe monatlich im Oktober
1923 und april 1924
explodiert seine marklos und er tötet
jede Woche
ah okay wow das kann und will ich mir
gar nicht vorstellen das ist der reinste
Horror versteht mich nicht falsch ein
Mord mit einer Waffe oder Totschlag mit
Fäusten die sind nicht weniger grausam
und schrecklich doch dieser Art zu töten
hat etwas das nicht ganz besonders
verstört vielleicht weil es so
unmittelbar ist so intim es gibt kein
Messer keine Kugel keine Faust die nach
dem Schlag sofort zurückzoggt
stattdessen einfach nur die Hände und
vor allem auch Zähne des zählt das
tödlich in den Hals des unglücklichen
Opfers verkrallt bestialisch und dann
natürlich auch die Tatsache dass uns
dieser bis so unmenschlich vorkommt weil
wir ihn eher Tieren zuordnen würden oder
eben einem Vampir deswegen ist ja auch
klar woher der Name Vampir von Hannover
herkommt
und genauso klar ist warum er oft auch
der schlechter oder Metzger von Hannover
genannt wird
nach seinen Taten so sagte es später aus
bricht Hermann oft zusammen und schläft
ein
dann wäre es vorhin gehört macht er sich
einen starken Kaffee und beginnt die
Leichen zu zerlegen und zu zerstückeln
Teile spürt er im Klosett herunter Teile
lässt er im Stadtwald von Hannover der
Eilenriede Verschwinden der Rest landet
in der Leine die direkt hinter Hermanns
Haus entlang fließt Hamann ist gründlich
und systematisch die Köpfe nahm ich
zuletzt vor erzählt er 1924 im Prozess
mit dem kleinen Küchenmesser Schnitte
ich die behaarte Kopfhaut ringsherum vom
Schädel und zerlegte sie in ganz kleine
Streifen und Würfe den Schädel legte ich
mit der wagenfläche auf eine Bastmatte
und deckte unten darüber und die
klopftöner abzuschwächen
ich schlug mit der scharfen Seite eines
Balls den Schädel immer herumdrehend die
nette auseinander das Gehirn kam in den
Eimer die kleinen Knochen warf ich in
die Leine gegenüber dem Schloss
oder ich ging in die allen Rede dort wo
es zum fähig ist warf die Stücke
heimlich vor mich hin trat sie den Sumpf
nur wenn ich eine Leiche sehr eilig
beseitigen musste kann möglicherweise
einmal ein Schädel unter klopften das
Wasser geraten sein die Kleider habe ich
verschenkt das meiste ein dran aus Liebe
anderes verkaufte ich oder lies es
verkaufen
na das sind mehr schöne Geschenke für
einen Geliebten und diese unzerklopften
Schädel führen die Polizei schließlich
auf die Spur des Serienmörders
allerdings mit einigen Umwegen zwischen
dem 17 Mai und 13 juni 1924 tauchen vier
Schädel auf zwei werden mitten in der
Stadt an der brückmühle hinter dem
Leineschloss angespült alle wurden
offenbar mit einem scharfen Instrument
vom Rumpf getrennt
doch noch immer bleibt die Polizei viel
zu untätig sucht nach natürlichen
Erklärungen etwa Grabräubern die zu
jener Zeit ihr Unwesen trieben und die
Schädel im Fluss entsorgt haben könnten
dann finden Kinder auf einer Wiese einen
Sack mit menschlichen Knochen und ein
fünfter schädeltaucht auf
es gibt Gerüchte über Menschen fallen
über Kinder die in Kellern verschwinden
und Jungs die im Fluss versenkt werden
auf dem Markt zer Menschenfleisch
verkauft worden behaupten manche und ein
Werwolf gehe um doch niemand verdächtigt
Fritz Haarmann wirklich nicht Nachbar
wundern sich ja schon über nächtliche
Knopf und hackgeräusche einer waren
sogar die Nachbarskinder nicht zum
Hamann zu gehen denn dort ging zwar
viele Knaben rein aber nur wenige Kinder
wieder heraus andere beobachten das
Hamann ungewöhnlich oft mit einem
zugedeckten Eimer zum Korsett geht das
im Hof des Hauses liegt was ist mit Frau
Engel und Frau Wege Henkel den er immer
wieder Kleidung von Kindern und jungen
Männern verkauft was ist schließlich mit
Hans Kranz seinen geliebten und Partner
in crime zumindest bei kleineren gain
und was ist vor allem mit der Polizei
vielleicht will man ja auch gar nicht so
genau hinsehen schließlich ist der Mann
auf den so viele Hinweise und Gerüchte
deuten in Gottesdiensten erst ein Zufall
bringt die Polizei endlich auf die
richtige Spur Harman Gerät am Bahnhof in
einen Streit und wird wegen Bedrohung
eines Jugendlichen verhaftet am 23.06
durchsucht die Polizei seine Wohnung und
findet zahlreiche teilweise
blutbefleckte Kleidungsstücke die jungen
Männern zu gehören scheinen
Hamann bleibt in Haft wird verhört und
gesteht am 1 Juli sieben Morde kurz
darauf senkt das Verkehrsamt Hannover
mit einem Wehr den Wasserstand der Leine
hunderte suchen im Flussbett nach
Leichen teilen und finden mindestens 300
menschliche Überreste die von mindestens
22 Personen der Mörder ist gefasst und
langsam wird das ganze Ausmaß seiner
Verbrechen deutlich man muss an dieser
Stelle auch sagen dass die Polizei einen
mit Schuld daran trägt das haben unsere
lange morden konnte
Vermisstenanzeigen wurden nicht weiter
verfolgt Hinweise ignoriert und offenbar
gern weggeschaut wenn es um eigenen
Spitzel ging nachdem der Fall erst
deutschlandweit und dann international
für Aufsehen sorgt müssen schnell
Erfolgsmeldungen her die vom eigenen
Versagen ablenken wie sie später
herausstellt wurde Harman in der U-Haft
massiv gefoltert die Beamten
malträtieren Hamann mit Fäusten Stiefeln
und Gummischläuchen sie stellen Schädel
und einen Sack mit Knochen in seiner
Zelle auf die Schädel sind von innen rot
erleuchtet und Harman wird eingeredet
die Seelen der Toten würden ihn holen
wenn er nicht gesteht Hamann gesteht da
muss ich jetzt aber ganz ehrlich
gestehen mein Mitleid hält sich da
wirklich ein Grenzen das war eine
absolute beste ein Monster aber der
Mörder war gefasst und die Indizien
waren eindeutig jetzt ging es nur noch
darum vor der Öffentlichkeit gut
darzustellen vom 4 bis 19.12 1924 steht
Hermann vor Gericht angeklagt wegen
Mordes an 27 Menschen
neuen Taten besteht er bei weiteren 12
ist er sich nicht sicher
hält es aber für möglich von den sechs
Taten die er bestreitet können ihm fünf
nachgewiesen werden
Harman scheint die Aufmerksamkeit die
ihm der spektakulärer und weltweit
beachtete Prozess verschafft zu genießen
Zitat wenn ich so gestorben wäre dann
wäre ich beerdigt worden und keiner
hätte mich gekannt so aber Amerika China
Japan und die Türkei alles kennt mich
der Prozess endet mit einem Todesurteil
für Fritz Hamann auch Hans granz bekommt
als mit Täter die Todesstrafe als
Hermann ihn aus der Haft heraus
entlastet wird sein Prozess neu
aufgerollt und das Urteil zu 12 Jahren
Zuchthaus umgewandelt am 15 April 1924
wird Fritz Herrmann im Hof des
gerichtsgefängnisses in Hannover mit dem
Fallbeil hingerichtet einer der
schlimmsten Serienmörder Deutschlands
ist tot doch seine Geschichte ist nicht
zu Ende sie lebt wie bei jedem
Verbrechen im Leid der Angehörigen der
Opfer weiter und Harman Witze einen
kulturellen Phänomen
bald gibt es Lieder und Romane über ihn
berühmte Filme wie m eine Stadt sucht
einen Mörder und Der Totmacher mit Götz
George basieren aus seinem Fall und
unzählige Serien Blockbuster und
Bestseller über Serienkiller werden von
ihm inspiriert in den 20ern macht ein
Gassenhauer die Runde der aus dem
schrecklichen Geschehen eine beinahe
niedliche kinderschreckgeschichte macht
warte warte nur ein Weilchen bald kommt
Harman auch zu dir mit dem kleinen
hackebällchen macht der Schabe Fleisch
aus dir aus den Augen macht der Sülze
aus dem Hintern macht der Speck aus den
Damen macht er Würste und den Rest den
schmeißt der Weg der Fall hat aber auch
konkrete und bittere Auswirkungen
homosexualität ist in den frühen 20er
Jahren zwar verboten wo sie jedoch
einvernehmlich und Erwachsenen vollzogen
wird da schaut der Staat oft weg
1924 im Gefolge des hamann-prozesses
wird die Verfolgung männlicher
homosexueller allerdings intensiviert
die Anzahl der Verhaftungen und
Verurteilungen aufgrund des Paragraphen
175 schießt in die Höhe und bleibt auf
hohem Niveau bis die Verfolgung
schließlich im Dritten Reich ihren
grausamen Höhepunkt erreicht hä das ist
doch auch total absurd oder nicht ich
meine wenn Männer Frauen töten dann
fängt doch auch keiner an plötzlich
heterosexuelle Männer zu verfolgen oder
naja aber so war nun mal leider die Zeit
und es ist echt gut dass dieser
Paragraph ersatzlos abgeschafft wurde
ich finde es nur echt übel dass das erst
1994 geschehen ist damit sind wir am
Ende unserer Episode Mirko wie geht's
dir mit der Geschichte ja wirklich eine
unfassbare Story vor allem natürlich die
Taten selbst dass so viele Menschen auf
so grausame Weise sterben mussten und
das alles in einem Umfeld das durch
Armut und Verzweiflung nach dem Ersten
Weltkrieg und die Weltwirtschaft
gezeichnet war die taumelnde Weimarer
Republik ich bin mir sicher dass alles
hat dazu beigetragen dass er seine
mordlos so lange unbemerkt ausleben
konnte in dieser schwierigen Zeit war es
nichts Ungewöhnliches dass junge
Menschen einfach verschwanden Aman war
auf jeden Fall ein Kind seiner Zeit und
das Ergebnis seiner Umgebung und
trotzdem eine extreme Ausnahme ich meine
es ist total krass wie haben und das
heutige Bild von Serienkiller geprägt
hat und was mich dazu auch noch total
aufregt dass er damals schon so viel
Aufmerksamkeit bekommen hat und zu
seiner Zeit schon in der internationalen
Presse aufgetaucht ist ja das fand er ja
ziemlich geil ich meine wir sprechen
jetzt heute auch drüber aber es hat uns
auch einfach so unglaublich entsetzt
aber beruhigend ist so etwas für
heutzutage sichern nicht mehr möglich
das war's für heute vielen Dank fürs
zuhören und wir hoffen dass Sie bei der
nächsten Folge wieder mit dabei seid bei
Tatort Deutschland Spezial euer Mirko
und von Natalie die grausamen
Geschehnisse rund um den Massenmörder
Fritz Hamann haben wir erzählt mit dem
Schriftstück von Theodor Lessing Hamann
die Geschichte eines Werwolfs Ralf J
pohles der Fall Fritz Hamann Werwolf von
Hannover zur Instabilität des dritten
einem Artikel des NDR dem Podcast Fritz
Hamann der Kannibale von Hannover sowie
Wikipedia und einem Dossier von Thomas
Christis der Massenmörder Fritz Haarmann
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Antonia
Haier Produktion serdarinis